chers camarades permettez moi avant de
commencer mon propos d'avoir une pensée
pour quelqu'un qui aurait voulu être
parmi nous ce matin c'est martine aubry
ma chère anne merci pour ton accueil
toujours important dans cette belle
ville dont tu porte les couleurs et
j'espère qu'elles mèneront loin dans les
défis que tu as posé pour les futurs
jeux olympiques
bon courage merci merci à ces deux
millions d'hommes et de femmes qui sont
venus voter alors que l'on disait que
ceci était impossible
improbable merci à eux qui malgré les
mots qui malgré les reportages ti malgré
la titraille des journaux sont quand
même venus poser leurs bulletins
parce qu'ils ont confiance dans la
gauche que nous internes ont
collectivement
merci aux responsables politiques aux
premiers fédéraux du parti socialiste
mais pas simplement tirons organiser
concrètement sur le terrain
ces primaires citoyennes
merci à christophe borgel et rachid des
mâles qui ont organisé le cnop
il en avait bien besoin merci aux
présidents des plus de 7000 bureaux à
leurs assesseurs qui ont fait en sorte
que ces primaires puissent être
organisées dans les meilleurs conditions
merci à thomas clay qui a bien sûr et
très notre responsable à tous
si porter la responsabilité de ces
primaires et qui a dû affronter comme
nous maintenant les positions les
analyses les anathèmes d'un certain
nombre de médias merci thomas d'avoir
tenu dans la broye merci aux candidats
jean luc bennahmias s'il ya pinel
françois de rugy
vincent peillon arnaud montebourg
merci à leur directeur de campagne
j'envoie quelques-uns ici mathieu
hanotin j'ai vu didier guillaume dans la
salle
merci pour le travail que vous avez
accompli je vois gilles jazzanova là bas
tu me fais des signes merci à manuel
valls pour son discours le soir du
second tour où il nous a demandé
malgré le résultat de rester unis dans
la bataille
six semaines merci au président de la
république qui a eu la hauteur de vue le
courage de ne pas se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle
d'autres devraient dans d'autres
conditions sont inspirés aujourd'hui et
se retirer pour que le débat sérieux
nécessaire pour la france ait lieu
merci à toi benoît qui a fait souffler
le vent frais de tous les renouveau tu
as donné ses lettres de noblesse à cette
phrase du philosophe merleau ponty
vincent peillon n'est pas là il me le
pardonnera c'est parfait le monde et ce
que nous voyons est ce qu'il faut nous
apprendre à voir dans son intervention
dans des interventions il y avait à la
fois la description du monde tel qu'il
est et l'anticipation de ce qui va
advenir et comment la gauche les
socialistes doit se comporter dans ce
monde qui vient merci d'avoir été fier
courageux et rassembleur dans ce débat
j'imagine
j'imagine ta fierté
j'imagine qu'on émotions ce n'est pas
rien que mettre ses pas dans ceux de
françois mitterrand de l'aîné jospin de
ségolène royal ou de françois hollande
ce n'est pas rien d'incarner un pays qui
est confronté à mille difficultés
émile tension ce n'est pas rien d'être
président de la république dans un monde
incertain et dangereux ce n'est pas rien
d'avoir dans les mois qui viennent à
affronter à la fois le défi posé par
donald trump celui posé par monsieur
poutine celui posé par la dislocation de
la construction européenne mais aussi
nous le savons ce malheur qui peut
intervenir chaque jour avec les
attentats terroristes et je voudrais
avoir une pensée pour nos soldats qui se
sont bien comportés dans le groupement
que nous avons
ce n'est pas simple que c'est une grande
ambition que de devenir le candidat de
l'ensemble de la gauche pour diriger la
france une france où les français savent
c'est ils ne veulent plus mais le savent
pas encore c'est ils veulent une france
où nous avons la décomposition à droite
et la fragmentation à gauche une france
où tout est possible et même le pire
benoit tu sais sur benoit tu es l'espoir
d'un temps de la justice de la
social-écologie de la prévention de la
protection
alors je te dis ensemble ensemble nous
serons le point de convergence de toutes
les gauches et de tous les écologistes
ensemble nous serons avec toi et déjà ta
candidature en huit jours est devenu
incontournable
rien ne sera fait maintenant sans nous
tout sera fait avec nous c'est déjà le
premier succès le ta campagne
ensemble
nous donnerons à ce pays
ce dont il a besoin l'espoir le
renouveau ensemble nous ferons que tous
ensemble nous serons avec toi benoît et
dans quelques jours
nous ne créerons pas benoît président
mais à mon président attoub benoît